this is a YouTube only commercial or
advertisement or promo
that coca-cola did sort of explaining
how you would burn off calories by
drinking one can
up their delicious soda let's take a
look
no
we actually spice that so you can get
the poor thing there but the poor thing
is I need you
for basically they're trying to make it
seem like this fun cool being
having to burn off the calories that it
takes 23 minutes of exercise if you're
140 pounds for one little 12 and a can
of coke
I do something very perverse about this
is it not we want to grow that is her I
live at for pork
and it was it was all people exercising
really working hard like
I do all this so that I can eat pork you
know exactly who had accepted really
good they had appeared he has now become
the real thing and and
this ad is so well per sold any open
should sue for the slight tweak
pee-wee's Big Adventure theme
yeah but also the idea that you know
yes here you can leave your bike for 20
minutes your and you're entitled to a
coke despite the fact that
a coke has more sugar than the other
than the average adult should consume an
entire day
right poison yeah I mean that shit is
the you know and the course it's high
fructose corn syrup
we don't even get the actual sugar yet
to go to Mexico right and even barely
afford to go hyper goes out with her
like it
but the whole calorie thing being the
end all be all those
I think pretty much been established as
kind of a myth love dieting not that I
clearly have a weight loss
girl but you know i think thats very
much over simple buying the big yellow
this ad
credit brings up a good just you know
get outta work out then get a bit slow
down or should we head over before we
get too deep into the Kali part out what
my me doesn't it
the ideal what they're doing here seem
really 1207 the marketing tactics that
these
you know junk food companies you no use
to me
is completely pervasive and I did drives
me crazy did you guys read that study
that came out last week about how
diet soda you know help people lose
weight which was actually a study funded
by the American
their shot I'm shot its graphic is most
30 say that actually makes you crave
sugar admit it you know according to
convert to the benzene your body and I
don't think I already did not order a
ton
%uh awful food and then they get a diet
so I think matter of setting
yeah I anybody's interested in this
topic should see my friend Laurie David
movie fed up with a documentary meters
out all about this how it's not just you
know
color reimburses our how these you know
by drinking a can of soda it actually
spike your insulin it did it prevents
you from feeling satiated you know so
makes you hungrier
and it's a it's a major player in the
obesity epidemic
cook even coca-cola's watered brand the
funny
has salt NS yeah
said all the way both of us and that
should think you could stay thirsty
it's insane okay still then what is coke
doing here what it what are they
really what are the Martin people saying
like they're just saying we know the
people are more health-conscious
so we're gonna make it seem bon you know
when using this actual machine for
exercise
I do cardio not fun and actually its
board had to do anymore
its force me to cut them the stuff that
I die if they have that rube goldberg
thing at the gym I might consider going
to what you know but there's a big giant
hand gonna give me a coke at the end I
might you know
I want that for Pee wee Herman thing we
do that hoping to get the look in your
theory absolutely here with a coke n
roll down all the things got pushed in
your face when you open a bottle
problem that is a good point I guess
interposition coke is like a reward like
there's no better reward for exercise
you know
her then a coke bring a coke which
regularly better award for exercise been
doing something that reverses although
I've to a factor and is not quench your
thirst at all after the exertion you've
just gone through I have a marriage
properties
yet by the way call a little more info
on the average
soda drinker consumes about 2.6 glasses
each day
so this was 2.6 and the coke that would
mean about an hour upcycling
so this stuff is just not good for you
and but we do all the stories everyone
then attacked me and says
you know we should have our indulgences
attack anything
yes I drink some other stuff too but we
should be more aware
up what's going on hiatus sometimes food
as they say on Sesame Street you know it
%uh sometimes rude you know if I
if you have like a coke. every couple
weeks you know it's not going to be the
worst thing in the world for you
but yet 2.6 a day that and say so. final
thought that we could cook any credit
then
for all known and they are they're just
be a purely you know I'm just tryna
played Devils I does definitely happen
again yeah
the signs the least offensive product of
them are good enough
tap water and were overpaying for yeah
that's all south of Port Authority tap
water
I